I did a podcast on this. And, uh,
we're I think it was a week and a half ago where I really,
I do 30 minutes of timeline on exactly who was saying, what, at what time,
I'm not trying to make excuses for Trump here.
I just want people to understand the truth.
I'm Dave Rubin, and this is the Rubin report reminder guys.
You can get all of our episodes days early and totally ad-free at Rubin
report.com. And joining me today is a former Navy seal.
The Congressman from Texas, his second district and author of fortitude,
American resilience in the era of outrage, Congressman Dan Crenshaw.
Finally, welcome to the Rubin report.
Great to be with you, Dave, we've.
Been trying to pull this off for a long time, but I guess it took,
it took a pandemic to, uh,
for us to accept Skype as the only way we could make it happen.
Yeah, that's true. I was supposed to come through LA for, uh, my book tour,
as you know, we had some events planned together, but, um, you know,
life happens, right?
Life happens, indeed. It does. All right. Well,
let's start with the stuff that we got to get out of the way, no matter what,
before we get into the book and your story and everything else,
which is just Corona virus, sort of where we're at,
I'm really curious your thoughts on the stimulus package and the way we watched
it sort of unfold, but just generally,
can you talk about what it's like to be in Congress right now in a time of truly
unprecedented happenings?
Yeah, it's odd in the same way that it's probably odd for everybody else.
You're trying to continue doing your job. Hopefully you still have your job and,
but you're trying to do it from home. You're trying to, to,
to be as effective as you were before, but you're,
but you're doing it from home. Uh, and that's, that's difficult. Um, uh,
more psychologically than, than logistically,
we can make an app and logistically our office is still operating as normal. Um,
the there's,
there's the frustrating thing about how this has played out from a congressional
standpoint is, is how the partisan games didn't really stop.
And w whereas we maybe thought they would, uh, we,
I think I had some hope that they would mostly because they, they were stopping,
uh, to an extent, I I'll,
I'll never forget Chuck Schumer on TV that Saturday and late February talking
about how bipartisan this rescue package was going, and it was going well,
good talks. He said, who? He said, surprisingly good bipartisan talks.
And then it all blew up the next day. And he quickly shifted tax and, and,
uh, and, and went right along with Pelosi's demands of, uh,
this crazy progressive wishlist. Ultimately, the,
the package went through days later, um, after millions of jobs have been lost,
but ultimately went through, and it was basically the same package.
Anybody who argues otherwise as being totally intellectually dishonest, um,
you know, the changes were minor and could have been agreed to that weekend.
That was extremely disappointing. That was also a turning point. I think,
I think we all noticed a turning point,
right then that came from the left-wing media.
And that turning point was Trump is to blame for millions of deaths.
That's right. That was the new, that was the,
that's been the new narrative and it hasn't stopped. Um,
and in fact it shifts slightly. Okay. Um, you know,
you saw it shift from, uh, from saying, Hey, there's a,
the Trump's travel restrictions from China. Weren't really travel restrictions.
It was, you know, he could have done more. All right. Well,
that's a dishonest talking point because the reality is the people coming from
China after January 31st were American citizens or green card holders.
So now you're going to have to explain to me why we shouldn't be repatriating
our own citizens. Okay. I mean, is it just really disingenuous or remarks?
Um, now the new talking point is that they didn't do anything in February. Okay,
fine. So the travel restriction was good. We agree with that,
even though we didn't at the time. And even though Democrats were in charge,
they never would have put those travel restrictions then fine.
But Trump didn't do anything in February,
except for except deny the whole thing. Well, again,
is this really an honest talking point? Um, you know, with 2020 hindsight,
could we have done more? Yes.
But with the facts that we had at the time I questioned what,
what exactly you think they should have done, um,
more PPE production and ventilator production, more testing production. I,
I agree with all of that. I just don't think it's,
I just don't think it's reasonable to be looking back in time and saying you
made this decision differently than I would have made this decision,
because that's just not true.
That the toughest part of doing what you guys have to do in terms of preparing
for something like this,
because right now the hindsight thing is just driving me crazy when you hear it
from the media that, Oh,
suddenly they're saying everybody knew this was coming in February.
And it's like, you know, there were, I think three,
possibly four democratic debates in February. The last one in February,
I believe was February 25th.
It was coronavirus was not mentioned in any of them.
It wasn't mentioned until the one where they only had Biden and Bernie in a
room alone because of coronavirus that was already into March.
So you see everybody it's like, yeah, now that we see the score of the game,
yeah. We can tell you everything that you did wrong before,
but that's not really how you can prepare as a, as a government.
A hundred percent true. I I'm about to release a video on,
on this exact thing. Um, I did a podcast on this and, uh, we're,
I think it was a week and a half ago where I really,
I do 30 minutes of timeline on exactly who is saying, what, at what time,
I'm not trying to make excuses for Trump here.
I just want people to understand the truth and you made another good point.
I didn't even bring up that point in my timeline of like,
they weren't talking about this. Nobody was talking about this in late February,
Pelosi and DeBlasio were telling people to go celebrate the Chinese new year,
go out, don't be afraid, and I'm not blaming them.
They had the same set of facts that we all did.
I don't think they're responsible for people's deaths either. I think,
I think this is a bad situation that we didn't quite expect. I also point out,
you know, in Italy, they didn't shut down their society until March 10th, Spain,
not until March 14th, uh, that's way later than February,
as it turns out, you know, we,
we did our 15 days to slow the spread on March 16th.
Iran didn't even start until April 4th,
Sweden still hasn't started and probably never will. Um, you know, there's just,
these are really disingenuous attacks. And as it pertains to something like PPE,
even with hindsight, no, it,
it's not obvious that the PPE shortage was going to be there.
It's not like I think people simplify what information government officials
truly have and are capable of having. It's not like,
it's not like there's this final tally of N 95 mass and the government just
knows what they are and knows what they'll need. Well, no, I mean,
hospitals are also responsible for stockpiling in Houston. Uh we're well,
stockpiled, maybe because we've been through a lot of,
we've been through pandemics before we've been through hurricanes before our
hospital system, uh,
operates a little bit differently than maybe another hospital system that
doesn't feel they need a bunch of N 95 Massey.
That's not necessarily the federal government's fault. And again,
if we really want to point fingers, if we really want to go down this road,
I will point you to all the fact checkers that have confirmed that it's really
the Obama administration that didn't replenish our national stockpile then of,
of 95 mass after the H one N one virus.
But should I really blame them? I mean, that's another question,
but I really believe blaming blaming the Obama administration,
what crystal ball do they have
things they spent it on radiological protection and things like that. They,
you know, th th there's no ill intent here. And, uh,
and I would also point out that our hospital system has been strained,
but not broken. Uh,
nobody has been denied a ventilator unlike in places in Europe. Why? Because,
well, it turns out our profit driven healthcare system, uh,
has an excess of things like ventilators and ICU beds. I,
I went through the numbers on this, on a per capita basis.
The us has way more orders of magnitude,
more ICU beds and ventilators than any of these, uh,
Western countries or countries in Europe, any of them, including Germany.
And that's a product of our healthcare system.
It's an imperfect healthcare system. I wish it was different in a lot of ways,
but socialized medicine means less supply because you're basically saying
price controls and people need to understand these basic facts as we,
as we judge what could have been done and what should have been done.
So speaking of.
Could have been done what should've been done.
Can you just explain a little bit about how information actually gets
to you guys?
Like how does it get to a member of Congress that say in January,
there's sort of these initial reports of something going on? Trump does the, uh,
initial shutdown. I think it was on Jan last day of January, I think.
But like when does something actually get to your desk and how do you actually,
Oh, now this is something I got to talk to somebody about,
or do you pass it on to somebody and say, does this study make sense?
Or is anyone else seeing these reports?
Like how does some of that information actually turn into something actionable?
Yeah, that's an interesting question. Um, w we,
we don't have a whole lot of secret lines of information that the public doesn't
have. Oftentimes members of Congress are really operating off of the same set of
facts that most, uh, people in the media are,
or most members of the public. Uh, the difference is we,
we have sets of professionals that we can rely on to sift through all of the
information and, and place that against prior policy,
uh,
compare that against prior legislation and talk about it in legislative terms.
This is we, we, we, we have, I just have a team that helps me do that, so that,
you know, I, I'm not, uh, I'm not a journalist trying to do it all myself.
And so, uh, that's a huge advantage as far as,
as sifting through the information and making sure that we get it correct.
If you're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about politics,
instead of nonstop yelling, check out our politics playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode playlist, all right, over here,
and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.